es geht voran in berlin grüne und fdp
geben der spd die erste chance ampel
schlägt jamaika und damit steigt die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass der nächste
kanzler olaf scholz heißt wenn er die
mehrheit findet im bundestag ende
oktober kommen die 735 neun abgeordneten
zur ersten sitzung zusammen und der
plenarsaal wird anders aussehen
mehr frauen mehr junge mehr mit einer
migrationsgeschichte neue abgeordnete
neue ideen weg frei für die ampel
darüber sprechen wir mit vier jungen
parlamentariern jetzt in der phoenix
runde
phoenix runde
schönen guten abend ganz herzlich
willkommen aus berlin ja ich darf meine
gäste vorstellen vier parlamentarier
dies alle eben jetzt geschafft haben bei
dieser wahl in den bundestag zu kommen
jever ii ist bei uns für die spd 34
jahre alte tätig in der
wissenschaftskommunikation und sie
stammt aus aachen ihre eltern kam 1986
aus südkorea und als sie elf jahre alt
war da sollte die familie abgeschoben
werden sie will sich für einen starken
sozialstaat einsetzen und ich begrüße
mohammed al hanak das für die fdp im
bundestag 32 jahre alt betriebsleiter
bei der abwasserbeseitigung in grafenau
im bayerischen wald mit elf kam er mit
seinen eltern aus dem irak dorthin und
dem bundestag will der anwalt der
handwerker und facharbeiter seien
und herzlich willkommen emilia fester
für bündnis 90 die grünen sie ist die
jüngste abgeordnete im bundestag 23
jahre alt freischaffende
regieassistentin und zieht für die grüne
jugend hamburg in den bundestag ein und
sie will für generationengerechtigkeit
kämpfen und herzlich willkommen
maximilian merseburg für die cdu sitzt
er im bundestag 29 jahre alt jurist er
hat das direktmandat im wahlkreis
stuttgart 2 gewonnen und dort war es ja
auch schon im stadtrat und er möchte
klima und wirtschaft versöhnen und er
ist der einzige der mit unter 30 jahren
ein direktmandat gewonnen hat also in
vier herzlichen glückwunsch für die wahl
zum bundestag jetzt wissen wir das ist
eine auf eine ampel hinausläuft frau
rieso sieht es erst mal aus fdp und
grüne haben gesagt sie wollen mit der
spd jetzt eben zu dann den tisch gehen
und schauen was da geht wie wichtig ist
das für sie oder was für ein gefühl ist
dass das man dass sie denken jetzt die
spd wird den kanzler stellen weil als
sie sich beworben haben für den
bundestag war dass er wahrscheinlich
noch nicht so absehbar es freut mich
natürlich total also ist hat mich riesig
gefreut dass das jetzt auch so zügig
gegen dass es sehr effizient war dass
die gespräche anscheinend auch sehr
vertraut und vertraulich liefen und also
wenn der nächste bundeskanzler
sozialdemokrat ist freue ich mich
natürlich riesig denn das war natürlich
auch das ziel das wir wahlkampf gemacht
haben als spd und was denken sie wie
viel muss die spd den grünen und der fdp
ja
sozusagen nahe kommen oder sachen von
sich aufgeben und damit das funktioniert
mit der ampel also lasst scheitert er
ganz klar gesagt es geht jetzt darum
dass man gemeinsam wirklich auf
augenhöhe noch mal miteinander spricht
und dann geht es glaube ich nicht darum
was muss wer aufgeben oder abgeben
sondern wirklich dass man sagt was ist
das gemeinsame ziel das ziel ist es den
staat zu modernisieren das ziel ist eine
bessere digitalisierung und den
klimaschutz voranzubringen und natürlich
bringen wir als spd dann nochmal die
soziale note mit ein dass wir sagen wir
wollen dass auch sozial verträglich
machen aber dass wir jetzt schon darüber
sprechen was wir abgeben müssen greift
da hab ich in gesprächen schon ein
bisschen voraus schon sehr diplomatisch
hier vor fenster wie die grünen sind
vorgeprescht die haben als erster gesagt
wir machen das jetzt mit der ampel bevor
die fdp noch vor sagen konnte die ja
eigentlich gesagt hat ist sie ganz gerne
auch jamaika gehabt hätte wie sehen wie
hoch sehen sie die chancen dass das
wirklich klappt mit der ampel
also wir haben ja der fdp erst mal
angeboten beziehungsweise vorgeschlagen
dass wir jetzt in drei er gespräche mit
der spd eintreten die fdp hat das
angenommen und dementsprechend sehe ich
jetzt auch ganz optimistisch diesen
gesprächen gegenüber weil genau ich
glaube wir haben da zu erwarten dass es
wieder ernsthafte sinnvolle gespräche
werden über die zukunft dieses landes
und solange die fdp und die spd damit
uns als grünen an einem strang zieht
sehe ich da groß es kommen aber ist es
eher die koalition die sie sich auch
gewünscht hätten
mein jugendverband die grüne jugend hat
sich ja sehr deutlich für eine ampel
ausgesprochen für die bin ich angetreten
dementsprechend dürfte es keine
überraschung sein dass ich mich sehr
darüber freue dass wir jetzt richtung
ampel zeigen trotzdem ist natürlich
wichtig auch jamaika weiterhin nicht
auszuschließen denn wir brauchen an der
stelle natürlich auch weiterhin die
alternativ offenheit um sagen zu können
dass wir dass es keine ampel um jeden
preis geben dass wohl jeder mann ja das
stelle hinaus klingt soll es helfen sie
geben also hochtreiben
was heißt die preise hoch halten es geht
darum die allerbesten lösung für dieses
land zu finden ich bin der überzeugung
dass das mit der ampel geht wenn sich
das als richtig herausstellt dann müssen
wir weiter überlegen okay gut
wie wichtig ist dass die fdp jetzt sagt
wir machen die ampel obwohl er viele in
der fdp auch gesagt haben eigentliche
jamaika ist eigentlich das was für uns
besser passt also ich hatte tatsächlich
keinen bei der fdp gesorgt hat
es muss eine jamaika sein oder ampel und
sind die inhalte sehr wichtig ich meine
wir wollen auch natürlich unsere
wählerinnen und wähler nicht enttäuschen
und ja es wäre es kann richtung ampel
gehen oder auch jamaika also ich würde
jetzt nicht jammern ausschließen aber
natürlich wer die meisten wo wir mit weg
koalition die meisten inhalte
durchbringen können die bevorzugen mir
die fdp okay noch ein bisschen abwarten
herrmanns worten ja herr bock wie
enttäuscht sind sie dass es jetzt
erstmal in richtung ampel geht und nicht
in richtung jamaika
naja ich bin erst mal enttäuscht über
das wahlergebnis das muss man einfach
anerkennen wir haben da eine ganz große
wahlschlappe leider bekommen wir haben
leider nicht so ein ergebnis bekommen
wie wir uns das erhofft hatten und das
war eine große enttäuschung und das hat
natürlich dazu geführt ich glaube so
ehrlich muss man auch sein dass wir
einfach nicht am drücker sind wir müssen
erstmal kleine brötchen backen das ist
halt einfach so in der demokratie dass
wir jetzt erstmal hinten anstehen müssen
aber ich glaube das thema
regierungsbildung ist letztlich noch
nicht durch dass es noch ein sehr langer
weg insbesondere für eine ampelkoalition
wenn man jetzt auch gerade
anhört was ich in den letzten stunden
schon wieder getan hat cem özdemir
spricht davon dass man jetzt das
tempolimit als low hanging food doch
einführen soll ich weiß nicht wie
christian lindner das sieht deswegen
glaube ich dass da noch einige
sollbruchstellen in dieser ampel
konstanz konstellation auch wir warten
erstmal ab als cdu/csu und ich glaube
wir sind grundsätzlich als partei der
verantwortung auch immer bereit
regierungsverantwortung zu übernehmen
wenn das eben an auf uns noch zukommen
sollte und ansonsten kürzt leider auch
zur demokratie dass man manchmal in der
opposition landet aber damit hätten sie
wahrscheinlich eben nicht gerechnet als
sie kandidiert haben für den oder als
sie sich auf den weg gemacht haben diese
karriere anzustreben als parlamentarier
sind jedoch wahrscheinlich davon
ausgegangen dass die cdu weiterregiert
sowie die so viele jahre regiert hat ist
das richtig
natürlich haben wir uns das erhofft
natürlich rechnet man nicht damit dass
man so eine wahl schlappe kassiert
das ist absolut richtig aber man
kandidierte er für ein parlament und
nicht für eine regierung
ich möchte vor allem für meine heimat
stuttgart in berlin der gute vertretung
sein möchte da die interessen meiner
heimatstadt vertreten ich möchte dass
wir sie haben vorher schon gesagt klima
und wirtschaft vereinen weil wir wollen
den wohlstand auch die vielen
arbeitsplätze die guten jobs die guten
unternehmen hier halten wenn wir die
transformation zu einem klimaneutralen
und klimafreundlichen industrieland
schaffen soll das nicht gegen die
wirtschaft gehen und wird es auch nicht
gegen die wirtschaft gehen dafür möchte
ich mich einsetzen wenn es dann eben in
der opposition ist dann ist es so schön
wäre natürlich gewesen sind wir in der
regierung weiter noch mehr einfluss
darauf haben ja nun sind sie alle
vertreter einer sehr jungen generation
der bundestag wird jünger der ist jetzt
in deutschland 47 5 jahre alt das ist
zwei jahre jünger als der letzte
bundestag und die gesellschaft wird
älter aber der bundestag wird jünger ist
eigentlich interessante entwicklung frau
die wenn sie jetzt die kollegen ihr hier
sehen kollegen und kollegen ist das ein
punkt wo sie sagen ja allein schon weil
wir alle jetzt jung sind und neue
abgeordnete haben wir auf jeden fall
ganz bestimmte dinge die uns verbinden
also ich glaube die erfahrung die wir in
den letzten tagen gemacht haben
verbindet schon unglaublich also wir
haben glaube ich schon so die erfahrung
gemacht dass jetzt gerade wirklich was
ganz aufregendes passiert dass da auch
einfach noch mal wirklich viele viele
neue abgeordnete reinkommen mit dem
bundestag man muss aber natürlich auch
es gehört auch zur wahrheit dass der der
altersdurchschnitt des bundestags immer
noch über dem altersdurchschnitt der
bevölkerung liegt das heißt es nähert
sich jetzt an trotzdem kann man ja nicht
sagen dass der bundestag jünger wird und
deswegen jetzt nicht mehr an die die
bevölkerung repräsentiert es sind auch
weniger frauen als im bundestag das ist
ja auch wieder gestiegen es sind
natürlich kleine schritte die wir machen
aber ich glaube wir wissen alle dass so
lange eine fraktion gibt die sich
einfach nicht umhin der frauenförderung
verschreibt dass wir vermutlich noch
sehr sehr sehr lange brauchen werden bis
wir wirklich eine parität im bundestag
haben und man sieht ja durchaus auch in
der verteilung das dass man da durchaus
auslegen kann woran es liegt dass die
letzten beiden bundestage weniger
paritätisch aufgestellt worden ja dann
hat wo sehen sie wo sehen sie
verbindungen dass sie sagen wir sind
hier eine junge generation wir müssen
dinge anders machen oder sagen sie ich
bin jetzt erstmal fdp oder teil der
ampel und die anderen sind dann halt
eben opposition wenn es denn so kommt
ich bin jung und sieht das ganz ehrlich
ich meine die demokratie hat ja gewählt
und diese richtung verbesserung das ist
klar auch die jungen leute brauchen die
älteren sozusagen die erfahrungen ich
sehe dass auf kommunaler ebene als
kommunalpolitiker sozusagen
wir sind die jungen leute sind auch auf
die älteren oder ältere generation
natürlich angewiesen aber auch andersrum
natürlich die älteren brauchen auch die
junge leute ich meine wir reden über
themen die auch ältere unbedingt nicht
gerade verstehen oder beziehungsweise
auch von uns lernen können und ich denke
dass beide seiten wichtig sind ja und
wir sind auch auf eine richtung wo wir
auch sozusagen also dass der bundestag
auch jünger wird und ich denke das ist
auch der richtige weg dann kommt so
etwas wäre für sie als junger mann ein
thema wo sie sagen das wäre für mich
ganz wichtig dass das jetzt auch in
seiner neuen regierung eben wirklich
umgesetzt wird
ich meine was für mich natürlich wichtig
ist ich kenne das ihr vor ort auch die
tatsächlichen interessen vor ort auch zu
vertreten und das schaffen wir junge
leute ja eigentlich am besten denke ich
mir mal halt für die jungen leute und
das ist der punkt profesor wie ist es
für sie waren in der grünen jugend
hamburg wo fühlen sie sich allein schon
durch die tatsache sind die jüngste
abgeordnete
das ist als dass sie sagen ich die
jugendpolitik ist sozusagen das wofür
ich kämpfen muss und wo würden sie sich
was wünschen sie sich dann davon einer
ampelkoalition von einer neuen regierung
also ich glaube wir erleben ja sowieso
gerade eine unfassbar politische jugend
die letzten jahre waren geprägt von zum
beispiel einer riesigen jugendbewegung
freitag futures die auf die straße
gegangen sind um für ihre zukunft zu
kämpfen und zur
generationengerechtigkeit gehören genau
diese gedanken rund um
klimagerechtigkeit und das möglichst
schnell dazu weil die jugend momentan
angst haben muss um ein leben auf einem
intakten planeten in wenigen jahren
schon und deswegen würde ich sagen
gehört genau dieses thema der jugend die
große zukunftsfrage der
sozialverträglichen lösungen der
klimakrise jetzt aufs tableau und das
bringen glaube ich gerade wir jungen
leute natürlich mit diesem druck von der
straße diese diskussionen innerhalb der
jungen generationen werden das
einbringen ich werde mich dafür stark
machen die bewegungen bzw die jugend in
eventuell auch ihre pluralität im
bundestag zu vertreten und diese stimmen
laut zu machen weil die in den letzten
jahren gerade von den konservativen
parteien schlicht und ergreifend nicht
gehört wurden kommen wir mal zu dem was
sie beide verbindet fdp und grüne wird
gerne börse burg dazu fragen bei der
bundestagswahl 2017 da hat die union bei
den wählern unter 30 da war sie mit 25
prozent die stärkste kraft jetzt ist sie
auf platz 3 glaube ich und grüne und fdp
sind weit vorne warum sind die jungen
und die gerade erst wähler nicht zur
union gekommen
gut ich denke mal wir haben die
wahlschlappe erlebt bei den jungen
wählern ist das einfach auch so dass die
volatilität auch am höchsten ist das
heißt einfach dass es natürlich einfach
schneller geht dort auch wieder zu
verlieren aber ich glaube auch wieder zu
gewinnen die wahl hat ja auch gezeigt
dass dieser medienhype umfeld ist future
der gerade auch angesprochen wurde eben
doch bisschen mehr luftblase war
stärkste kraft ist ja die fdp geworden
glückwunsch dazu herr haller halak das
ist ja auch in ordnung für uns ist das
natürlich ein bisschen blöd wir wollen
nächstes mal auch wieder stärkste kraft
werden auch bei den jungen menschen das
ist ganz klar aber das heißt für mich
auch klar dass wir nicht weil das
verfügt hinterherlaufen müssen wir
wollen klimaschutz das ist bei uns auch
im programm verankert sicherlich hat man
da als junger mensch vielleicht noch mal
ein größeres interesse dran aber wir
wollen eben nicht dieses konzept von
file is for future klimaschutz durch
sozialismus weil das wird nicht
funktionieren wenn wir in stahlwerken in
deutschland das wird hier abgebaut weil
wir ja die industrialisierung haben und
dann wird es in china wieder aufgebaut
dann haben wir null co2 eingespart
machen uns hier die wirtschaft kaputt
werden die arbeitsplätze verlieren
deswegen wir brauchen da einen klugen
weg das heißt über abgaben steuerung zum
beispiel den co2 preis den die
bundesregierung ja eingeführt hat unter
führung der cdu csu und über diesen weg
wirtschaftsverträgliche klimaschutz zu
betreiben wird funktionieren dieser weg
klimaschutz durch sozialismus wird nicht
funktionieren ok einfach der zu
wohlstandsverlusten führen sozialen
ungleichheit der fleck und das ist erst
die co2 ziele nicht einhalten das linke
knie hand nimmt sollte hätte jamaika
funktioniert frauen dass sich halt
anders also ich finde wenn man fragt was
ist das was wir einbringen oder was uns
verbinden sollte ist dass man viel mehr
die perspektive der der jungen leute mit
rein ins parlament das heißt nicht dass
wir nur politik machen für junge leute
oder dass wir nur jugendpolitik machen
aber wenn man sagt wow future ist eine
bubble die man jetzt irgendwie
vernachlässigen sollte da überschätzt
hat dann finde ich tut man vielen vielen
menschen einfach unrecht die sich
unglaublich engagiert haben und es geht
gar nicht darum ob sich das jetzt im
wahlergebnis niederschlägt sondern es
geht einfach um ehrenamtliches
engagement es geht um engagement von
jungen menschen es geht um die stimmen
von jungen menschen und was mir
persönlich wichtig ist ist dass man auch
diese perspektive wieder ein bringt weil
diese auch zum beispiel wären corona
sehr sehr zurückstecken musste und ich
find das ist das was uns glaube ich
vereint dass wir sagen wir haben ein
umfeld wir haben freundinnen und freunde
wir haben bekannte die sich für etwas
engagieren oder etwas unfair finden und
das einfach wirklich auch im parlament
vertreten sehen wollen deswegen würde
ich da ja mal so birk tatsächlich
komplett widersprechen
es ist einfach unfair gegenüber dem
engagement was viele menschen gezeigt
haben den letzten monaten und jahren
aber prof das ist
dazu
noch fester bitte entschuldigung ich da
wären eine leichte zeit verärgerung dass
hin kommt das an ich würde gerne einmal
noch ergänzen das verdeck eine
interessensvertretung ist weil das
gerade so klang und ja auch durch
falschdarstellungen richtung sozialismus
zum beispiel gerade so aufgefangen wurde
es verfügt keine interessensvertretung
sondern eine jugendbewegung die sich
dafür einsetzt dass die politik endlich
der wissenschaft zuhört und das ist ja
was was zum beispiel die grünen einfach
auch jetzt schon seit jahrzehnten tun zu
sagen die wissenschaft sagt uns doch
dass wir die klimakrise anpacken sollte
insofern ist frei die jetzt verfügte
einfach nicht gleichzusetzen mit anderen
ist interessensvertretungen sondern es
geht um eine jugend die aufgrund von
wissenschaftlichen von
wissenschaftlichen erkenntnissen angst
um ihre zukunft haben muss und deswegen
der politik sagt hört darauf was der
weltklimarat und sagt und kommt endlich
ins handeln und insofern ist es
eigentlich für mich keine frage ob wir
jetzt auch weil es vor future hören
sondern wir sollten uns auf grund dieses
weckrufs endlich auf den hintern setzen
und wirklich gute klima politik machen
weil es um alles geht und da wäre die
frage frau fest an sie heran lag wo
sehen sie da die schnittmengen mit der
mit den grünen oder wo können sie sich
auch vorstellen dass in
sondierungsgesprächen auch wirklich
schwierig ist gerade im beim thema
klimaschutz also es ist ja auch so dass
wir einen klaren auftrag bekommen haben
oder beziehungsweise die fdp hat den
klaren auftrag bekommen weil wir ja auch
tatsächlich ja sehr stark waren bei
erstwählern und wir wollen auch keine
enttäuschungen erleben halt und ich
denke dass jetzt der inhalt ja sehr
wichtig ist und ich denke dass wir
richtung klima einiges ich meine wir
haben selber nicht nur grün sondern auch
fdp wir haben einen ziel wir wollen auch
richtung klima was tun und ich denke da
werden wir uns in der mitte treffen
müssen dass wir auch tatsächlich eine
regierung bilden kann hat und
wir schauen jetzt wo wir uns am besten
sozusagen auch
mit wo sie sich treffen sie in dem sie
arbeiten in der abwasserbeseitigung das
ist ein umweltthema thema so ich habe da
spüren sie doch sicherlich auch dass das
ein thema ist bei den menschen denn also
das ist ja es ist natürlich und wiesen
thema ich meine die jungen leute
befassen sich damit ich meine warum sind
wir da so stark die fdp tut was für das
klima auch und ich bin selber ein
handwerker bzw habt da
umwelttechnischen beruf eine ausbildung
gemacht und für mich selber persönlich
ist auch klima ein riesen thema auch
nicht nur für junge leute sondern ich
als handwerker und ja da kommen sie
irgendwie zusammen das wirkt jetzt hier
wenn ich das jetzt hier so höre sie vier
habe ich den eindruck dass die ampel
etwas wahrscheinlicher ist also der my
car for free
sie wollten sich was würden sie sagen
sie war mit gesagt sie wollen sich für
einen stärkeren sozialstaat einsetzen
was ist für sie wichtig wo sagen sie ich
bin jetzt im bundestag und das will ich
erreichen das ist mir wichtig ich hatte
das vorher so ein bisschen angedeutet
aber ich bin auch eingetreten im
wahlkreis und hat gesagt wenn ich mich
umhöre sei es in der familie oder sei es
in der kneipe oder so dann sagt man
relativ häufig so etwas wie was das
super krass unfair wie dass ich mir
diese mieten nicht leisten kann aber ich
konnte mir die wohnung nicht leisten
oder dass man sagt es ist total unfair
dass jemand der sein ganzes leben lang
gearbeitet hat am ende im alter dann
überlegen muss wie kann ich mir gewisse
dinge noch leisten und dieses unfaire
ist glaube ich das was wir als als spd
einfach beseitigen wollen dass wir sagen
dieser gedanke dass etwas unfair das
ungerecht ist in unserer gesellschaft
das wollen wir halt angehen und das kam
wirklich in jedem bereich seien und
deswegen ist auch der klimaschutz ja
auch für uns zukunfts mission nummer
eins gewesen dass wir sagen
klimagerechtigkeit ist einfach auch
generationengerechtigkeit das geht
einfach grundsätzlich darum dass der
staat dazu da sein sollte das unfaire
abzuschaffen und für gerechtigkeit zu
stehen und das war uns schon also auch
in der haben die frage ist wie viel dann
der staat dafür sorgen muss dass es
jemanden besser geht also wie viel staat
muss sein da haben sie ja mit der fdp
jedoch einen ganz anderen
ansatz eigentlich eine andere
perspektive
aber ich glaube das macht es auch
spannend weil bei den liberalen also was
wären auch immer wieder merkt ist und
was wir ja auch als spd heftig wie
schätzen ist tatsächlich diese dieser
freiheitsgedanke und das ist um
bürgerrechte geht es um freiheitsrechte
geht und wenn man sich das jetzt
wirklich gemeinsam anguckt als puzzle
und koalition sondern normal puzzle wo
man gucken muss wie es zusammenpasst ist
es für mich nicht immer liegt unbedingt
ein widerspruch dass man freiheit und
gerechtigkeit nicht zusammen denken kann
sie waren ja alle auch in der
kommunalpolitik oder in der bunte grünen
jugend endlich aktiv also sie haben sie
sind jetzt keine politische neulinge ich
würde gern trotzdem von ihnen wissen
warum engagieren sie sich da und herr
merseburg warum warum haben sie sich
entschieden sich für die cdu zu
engagieren
und ich bin schon relativ lang lang
jetzt auch dabei der cdu ich habe mich
damals entschieden weil ich einfach in
der politik haben wollte die realistisch
ist die pragmatisch ist die anpackend
ist die aber auch werte hat grundwerte
ein wertegerüst auf dem man entscheidet
und das war für mich einfach ein gutes
ein gutes mittelmaß zwischen auf der
einen seite wirtschaftlichen interessen
aber eben auf der anderen seite auch
einer soliden der gesellschaftlichen
politik ihren baden württemberg
insbesondere haben wir damals den
ministerpräsidenten gestellt in den
stuttgarter oberbürgermeister und uns
ging es einfach sehr gut und es gibt es
auch immer noch sehr gut aber das hat
für mich einfach auch diese
leistungsbilanz der letzten jahrzehnte
gezeigt dass es eine gute politik ist
von der cdu und ich bin auch sehr
zufrieden mit dieser entscheidung ich
fühle mich sehr wohl frau förster warum
die grünen bei ihnen
also ich muss sagen politisch vielleicht
tatsächlich einfach schon immer ich
wollte mit acht schon selber wählen und
war ein bisschen beleidigt dass das
nicht geworden was tierschutz sehr
wichtig und ich wollte auch damals schon
die grünen wählen und deswegen war dann
glaube ich dass schritt in zuerst die
grüne jugend und dann auch in die partei
einzutreten total folgerichtig und
einfach schon zehn jahre alt als ich
dann schließlich mitglied geworden bin
ja okay also auch schon immer politisch
interessiert vori wie kam es bei ihnen
dazu dass sie gesagt haben ich gehe
jetzt nach in den stadtrat und für die
spd es war mir tatsächlich also sie
hatten es ja auch schon angesprochen
meine eltern kommen aus korea und bei
uns stand eine abschiebung an und das
war so als erste mal dass ich als kind
gemerkt habe dass diese entscheidung wo
man lebt oder wo man zu hause ist dass
das eine politische ist und wir haben
damals ganz viele briefe geschrieben wie
vermutlich viele familien die ein
ähnliches schicksal droht und wir haben
halt von verschiedenen parteien
unterschiedliche antworten bekommen und
diese dieser diese philosophie dass man
sagt egal woher man kommt man sollte
teilhaben können und sollte hier bleiben
können und sollte eine möglichkeit haben
das beste aus dem leben zu machen das
war für mich einfach die spd und dadurch
hat sich das einfach entwickelt durch
den persönlichen kontakt auch und jetzt
bin ich da 2014 im stadtrat und jetzt im
bundestag so aufregen und was ist das
für ein gefühl als sie jetzt zum ersten
mal im plenarsaal dann waren sie haben
sich das ja alles schon angeguckt sie so
müssen jetzt noch büro wohnung alles
organisieren gerade auch mit dieser
geschichte die sie so haben was war das
für ein ausgelöst bei ihnen es hat sich
einer der schönsten momente weil wir
hatten direkt in der ersten
fraktionssitzung die möglichkeit uns
alle neuen vorzustellen also 104
menschen alle etwa eine minute und man
hat von so vielen neuen abgeordneten
gehört ich bin 1997 eingebürgert worden
ich bin 2002 eingebürgert worden und als
meine eltern hierher kam hätten die nie
gedacht dass ihr sohn ihre tochter mal
hier im plenarsaal sitzen und das waren
diese gänsehaut momente wo dann auch
ältere abgeordnete gesagt haben dass das
da sieht man einfach wirklich auch wofür
die spd sehr sehr lange politik gemacht
hat und das ist auch für mich irgendwie
an einer der schönsten momente gewesen
in der letzten woche und ist einfach
großartig irgendwie herr alack sie haben
sich entschieden für die fdp und haben
sich das sicher oder ihre eltern sich
auch nicht vorstellen können dass sie
mal mit 32 im bundestag sind was für sie
für moment es ist für mich ein tolles
gefühl gewesen das ist klar aber warum
ich bei der fdp bin ich meine engagieren
oder engagiert habe ich mich immer schon
weil ich tatsächlich damals mit der
familie als ein elfjähriges kind hierher
kommen ich wurde sehr herzlich
aufgenommen
und ich wurde nicht irgendwie alles
anders angesehen von anderen kennen dann
damals und ich habe mich engagieren
wollen ich habe mich damals ehrenamtlich
engagiert irgendwann mal
dürfte ich christian linder natürlich
schon damals hat mich das
aufstiegsversprechen der stadt
angesprochen wo man herkommt aus welchem
elternhaus du kommst das hat gar keine
rolle gespielt die tatsächliche leistung
hat gezählt nicht meiner und das war der
punkt wo ich gesagt habe okay ich möchte
mich gerne für die fdp engagieren bin
mitglied geworden und engagiere mich
seit dem auch für die fdp weil ich als
eine der migrationshintergrund hat eine
handwerkliche ausbildung ausgeübt hat
schafft es in den bundestag und ich
wurde gefördert und natürlich kann man
auch fordern und ich denke das ist was
tolles und ich bin da sehr stolz dass
ich dabei der fdp bin und dass ich auch
natürlich auch gefördert worden sind das
finde ich toll ja das ist und dass sie
sozusagen danach ein vorbild sein
könnten für andere ich kann nicht nur
ein vorbild ich meine ich werde auch ein
vorbild sein für andere die eine
migrationsgeschichte haben und auch
natürlich auch für handwerker oder eine
oder welche die auch eine berufliche
ausbildung machen wollen ich denke dass
ich durch meine biografie zeigen kann
dass die aufstiegschancen gleich sind
egal was man macht sozusagen hatten dass
man die schau mal das problem ist ja nur
dass das ja nicht stimmt also dass die
aufstiegschancen immer noch nicht
überall gleich sind also wenn wir wenn
das so wäre dann würden wir vermutlich
sehr viel weniger ungerechtigkeit haben
also ich finde das ist total super dass
wir jetzt so divers aufgestellt sind und
dass man unterschiedlichen hintergrund
hat aber es ist ja immer noch so dass es
ja immer noch entscheidet wo man
herkommt was die familie gemacht hat was
das elternhaus hat und auch wie viel
geld man hat und das ist ja einer der
größten probleme die jetzt auch mal
haben die frage warum ich bei der fdp
bin ich wurde gefördert und das ist
jetzt das beste beispiel dafür ich wurde
gefördert und bin bei der fdp aus dem
grund es ist klar da muss man noch viel
einiges noch machen da ist noch
handlungsbedarf aber das ist der grund
jetzt gewesen warum ich bei der fdp bin
okay herr merseburg wenn jetzt ist im
moment eine zeit und auch leider auch
gerade bei ihrer parteilos wo man das
gefühl hat wenn menschen die menschen
miteinander umgehen ist nicht immer die
das die schönste art das kennen wir von
der spd auch das gab es auch so viele
kämpfe um die spitze wenn wir jetzt
sehen wir wie mit armin laschet um
gegangen wird wie jemand ja wo es ganz
viel kritik gibt was sind da haben sie
da mal gezweifelt an der art wie politik
gemacht wird
komplett neu es ist ja in der politik
leider gehört es einfach dazu dass es
manchmal ruppig zugeht das ist so aber
ich glaube das ist einfach jetzt gerade
der situation geschuldet wahlniederlage
dass es eben etwas schwieriger ist für
uns ich erinnere mich sie haben gerade
angesprochen bei der spd war es ganz
lange schwierig joschka fischer hat
glaube ich meine torte ins gesicht
bekommen und
das ist auch bei der fdp zum beispiel
nach philipp rösler nicht schön gewesen
das ist leider so in der politik aber
ich glaube wir wussten alle als man es
drauf eingelassen haben dass das so auch
teilweise sein kann aber was will ich
das system was wünschen sie sich für
ihre parade eigentlich gut ist wie wir
er weiß was wünschen sich entdecken für
meine partei wünsche ich mir natürlich
ich wünsche mir dass wir auf dem weg
kommen wie wir in zukunft wieder
deutlich bessere wahlergebnisse
einfahren können damit wir unsere idee
von politik umsetzen können dafür
brauchen wir meines erachtens eine
deutliche erneuerung wir brauchen vor
allem aber eine inhaltliche erneuerung
wir müssen wieder deutlicher machen
wofür wir stehen wir dürfen uns nicht
verstecken wir müssen selbstbewusstsein
wenn es darum geht unsere themen zu
formulieren und auch unterzubringen wir
stehen für unsere werte für das
christliche menschenbild bestehen aber
auch für eine soziale marktwirtschaft
mit der betonung auf marktwirtschaft und
das wollen wir selbstbewusst für ihre
arbeit ist sicher wenn wir das tun dass
wir auch in der zukunft wieder mehr
wählerinnen und wähler ansprechen wer
sollte der glaube an da werden wir die
großen herausforderungen unseres landes
nicht aber es inhalte werden doch über
menschen transportiert und über personen
und über köpfe und es gab eben ganz viel
kritik an der kandidatur von armin
laschet in vielen solltest dass es an
ihm lag dass das wahlergebnis so
schlecht war mit wem würden sie sich
denn den neuanfang und die erneuerung in
der cdu wünschen
ich glaube das ist jetzt noch nicht der
zeitpunkt darüber zu diskutieren weil
wir eben noch nicht wissen zu welcher
koalition es kommt natürlich die ampel
ist jetzt sehr wahrscheinlich das ist
einfach auch das betrachten der realität
können das sei aber an den gut fest ist
eben noch ein langer weg bis diese ampel
steht und wenn wir diese ampel hat na
gut also eine regierung wird es meines
erachtens nach nicht mit jemanden geben
der nicht auf dem dem gar nicht zur wahl
angetreten ist dh eine regierungsbildung
mit der union wird wahrscheinlich mit
armin laschet passieren wenn wir einen
oppositionsführer suchen dann kann ich
mir nicht vorstellen dass armin laschet
dann noch mit dabei sein möchte dann
werden wir uns ziemlich sicher personell
komplett neu aufstellen müssen werde es
dann wird das kann man jetzt noch nicht
sagen da habe ich jetzt auch gar keine
präferenz im moment wird mir war wichtig
dass wir da einen guten prozess bekommen
das wirtschaften die mitglieder dieses
mal richtig mitzunehmen einzubinden und
dann in einem sehr gesteuerten prozess
am besten über eine
mitgliederbeteiligung der neuen
parteivorsitzenden zu wählen der dann
eben unsere neuaufstellung personell ist
und gemeinsam dann mit dem team cdu und
auch inhaltliche neuaufstellung in die
nächsten vier jahre gehen kann und
meines erachtens nach dann die besten
chancen hat auch in vier jahren wieder
ein sehr gutes wahlergebnis
einzuspringen mitgliederbefragung ist
ein punkt die frage halt eben wie
transparent mann ist in allen parteien
wie sehr man ja die mitglieder mitnehmen
kann frau gibt es was wofür sie sich
fürchten wo sie denken oder habe ich
jetzt wirklich manschetten in den
nächsten vier jahren wenn sie so an ihre
zeit jetzt denken als abgeordnete also
fürchten gar nicht dass ich freue mich
wirklich darauf also es wird
herausforderungen geben
aber es fühlt sich gerade ganz richtig
an und weil es gerade mehrmals darauf
hingewiesen worden ist dass wir als spd
ja auch unsere erfahrungen haben was uns
jetzt glaube ich gerade auch so stark
macht ist wir haben das nicht getan wir
haben jetzt nicht unbedingt großen und
diskussion angefangen ich erinnere mich
noch daran dass wir im juni zwischen 13
und 17 prozent lagen und das wurde nicht
in frage gestellt ob olaf scholz der
richtige ist wir haben nicht gesagt das
wahlprogramm ist falsch wir haben nicht
gesagt die kampagne ist falsch und wir
haben nicht angefangen über einander
über twitter oder über die presse zu
reden und deswegen würde ich gar nicht
mal so sagen dass man oder aus meiner
erfahrung ist dass man braucht nicht nur
eine inhaltliche erneuerung wenn es mal
nicht gut läuft sondern es geht
vielleicht auch darum dass man mehr
miteinander spricht und weniger
übereinander und das andere ist also ist
es jetzt eine böse frage aber wurde der
letzte vorsitzender der cdu nicht auch
per mitgliederbeteiligung gewählt das
stimmt so
das ist richtig
hamburg na ja also es war eine
delegierten entscheidung wie der
parteivorsitzende gewählt wurde das ist
für mich nicht die art von mitglieder
entscheidung die ich mir jetzt für das
nächste verfahren wünsche ich werde es
gut wenn unsere mitglieder befragt
werden aber im endeffekt ist das ja nur
eine frage des des verfahrens nachher
geht es darum dass wir ebenfalls wir in
der opposition landen uns gut aufstellen
müssen personell und auch inhaltlich und
ich bin mir sicher dass das
funktionieren würde die frage ist eher
politik lebt von kompromissen und gerade
so ein neues bündnis wie die wie eine
ampelkoalition die so noch nicht gegeben
hat das heißt aber kompromisse heißt ich
muss auch immer was aufgeben von meinen
ideen vor fester wo gibt's denn für sie
rote linien wo sie sagen also wenn wir
das aufgeben dann verlieren wir
sozusagen unseren markenkern und das
geht nicht also das muss auf jeden fall
daran müssen wir auf jeden fall
festhalten gibt es so was für sie
ich glaube unsere partei in den letzten
wochen inzwischen ja auch schon ganz gut
dadurch geglänzt dass sie sich nicht
gegenwärtig ausspielt und jetzt diesen
verhandlungen auch nichts vorwegnehmen
wir haben ein gutes wahlprogramm
aufgestellt mit dem wir jetzt in diese
verhandlungen gehen und natürlich so
viel wie möglich rausholen wollen wir
sind bereit kompromisse zu machen
und wir sind aber dafür angetreten jetzt
eine sozial ökologische transformation
unseres wirtschaftssystems anzutreten
und dafür werden wir kämpfen rote linien
vermag ich nicht zu formulieren und bei
ihnen gab es aber auch ein bisschen
unruhe auch annalena baerbock war schon
zeigte sich enttäuscht sagte ich habe
fehler gemacht in diesem wahlkampf jetzt
sieht man sehr stark robert habeck der
nach vorne kommt ist das ein punkt wo
sie sagen oder wie bewerten sie das das
duo wie die miteinander umgehen sagen
sie wenn robert habeck angetreten wäre
hätten wir vielleicht bessere chancen
gehabt
die beiden sind geschlossen und wir
stehen auch weiterhin geschlossen hinter
unserer kanzlerkandidatin die nun nicht
das gros der wähler in hinter sich
vereinen konnte aber doch ja im
gegensatz zur letzten wahl sehr gute
wahlergebnisse einfahren konnte ich
glaube wir können zurückblicken auf
einen wunderschönen großen wahlkampf in
dem wir klar gemacht haben dass
klimaschutz das große thema unserer zeit
ist deswegen sprechen jetzt in dieser
runde ja zb auch schon fdp und spd so
lautstark über klimaschutz das ist ein
großer gewinn den wir in dieser wahl
gemacht haben mit annalena baerbock an
unserer spitze und ich habe größtes
vertrauen und wir stehen geschlossen
hinter ihr okay also alles ganz positiv
sieht es schon
wie ist es bei ihnen was würden sie
sagen gibt es punkte wo sie ja wo man
sie auf gut deutsch läuft ein bisschen
manschetten haben oder denken mal gucken
wie das so alles wird in diesen nächsten
dieser nächsten zeit ich meine uns sind
die inhalte wichtig wir haben 2017
bewiesen dass wir nicht unbedingt jetzt
regieren wollen koste es was es wolle
und das war unser ziel das wir dass eine
regierung ohne uns nicht möglich ist und
das haben wir ja geschafft und ich denke
jetzt dass wir inhalte durchbringen
können und ich denke ja irgendwo
komplize muss man eingehen und dann aber
eine rote linie zum beispiel
steuererhöhungen das geht gar nicht aus
das will ich natürlich nicht ehrlich
aber ich denke da werden wir uns sehr
einig kein problem und würden sie das
mit trage ich meine beim tempolimit wird
das natürlich ein thema sein aber
durch tempo limit sollte nicht unbedingt
jetzt die sondierungsgespräche
abgebrochen werden da kann man noch
erleben aber die frage die ich
eigentlich meinte es gibt es für sie
persönlich du bist du sowieso wo sie
sagen
tempolimit ist keine rote linie für mich
okay und ich denke es gibt auch wichtige
sachen wir sind jetzt hier auch
eine zeit wo wir viele themen unbedingt
behandeln müssen und
tempolimit ist irgendwo auch natürlich
dabei aber es muss sie es hat jetzt kein
forderung verglichen jetzt mit
steuererhöhung ich meine klima diesem
thema aber wenn wir es bekommen gerne
tempolimit nicht ein die fdp aber sagen
kann ich bin das ist sehr schade weil da
werden auch viele wähler enttäuscht
seien von der fdp ob es ist also wenn
wir jetzt ich hab' ich habe ja sie sagen
ja so regierung ist denn es gibt ja die
wir unbedingt durchsetzen ich sage jetzt
nicht dass wir tempolimit einführen
wollen das wollen wir gar nicht aber ich
meine es ist eine regierung die besteht
aus drei parteien und irgendwo müssen
wir kompromisse kompromisse eingehen und
uns ist wichtig wie es dann weitergeht
hier in deutschland und nicht auf
irgendwelche verbote sozusagen auch mal
traurig gibt es für sie rote linien wo
sie sagen da weil die fdp sagt ganz klar
gar keine steuererhöhungen jetzt haben
wir aber das problem dass von der auch
gerade den klimaschutz dann doch
irgendwo finanzieren muss bestimmte
maßnahmen da sagt die spd will ja da ein
paar mehr belastungen haben was wo
gibt's für sie rote linie ich mag ich
könnte jetzt mein ganzes oder unser
ganzes wahlprogramm runterbeten das
könnte darauf vermutlich auch und halak
auch und dann würden wir vermutlich den
ganzen abend ihr sitzen also das
wichtige ist ja wir sondieren wir
sondieren über die großen linien kommen
wir da zusammen sind die ziele die
gleichen oder ähnliche dass man sagt
okay wir wollen dahin die
steuererhöhungen da müssen wir darüber
sprechen weil es geht ja nicht darum
dass die steuer erhöhen wollen nur um
die steuern zu erhöhen sondern es geht
darum dass wir uns alle drei parteien
vorgenommen haben gewisse dinge zu
investieren und dann müssen wir uns
überlegen wie wollen wir das bezahlen ob
das jetzt über steuererhöhungen ist oder
über andere möglichkeiten da gibt es
sicherlich größere finanz expertinnen
und experten als mich die dann sagen
können okay gibt es dort alternativen
aber da jetzt was vorweg zugreifen würde
ich mir gar nicht anmaßen weil es wird
jetzt erstmal sondiert werden und dann
werden wir sehen ob wir in den großen
linien über einkommen und die ganzen
sachen was jetzt rote linien nennen wird
vermutlich erst bei den
koalitionsgesprächen die hoffentlich
dann auch bald an stattfinden noch
einmal diskutiert werden müssten das
muss man dann erstmal noch mal sehen wie
es die kleinen dinge gibt man wird ja
noch mal kompliziert frohe feste haben
sie ein vorbild in der politik gibt es
jemand wo sie sagen ja deshalb das ja
sowieso jemanden finde ich richtig der
der oder die hat wirklich gute politik
gemacht so würde ich da würde ich mich
gern daran orientieren
also ein großes vorbild tatsächlich aus
hamburg ist anna galina unsere
amtierende justizsenatorin die vorher
auch meine landesvorsitzende war die
mich immer sehr viel auf meinem weg
begleitet und unterstützt hat
genau und an ihr kann ich mich immer
ganz gut orientieren weil sie finde ich
ein sehr gutes gespür hat diplomatisch
sein kann und gleichzeitig sehr klare
linien aufzeigt er ähnlich wie
vielleicht auch unsere kanzlerkandidatin
ok frau die gibt es für sie ein vorbild
es gibt glaube ich ganz viele vorbilder
also ich hab also gerade auch wenn es
die politikerin die vor uns gekommen
sind also gerade auch die frauen in der
politik die uns den weg geebnet haben
ich habe persönlich im wahlkreis
natürlich mit ulla schmidt eine
politikerin gehabt die 31 jahre lang
auch bundespolitisch ganz schön viel
geprägt hat und was mich an ihm
imponiert hat ist dass sie sehr klar
gemacht hat sie es aus aachen sie macht
für aachen eine politik das hat man ja
immer auch angehört das hat sie ja nie
ich hatte ja vorhin erzählt wie ich zur
politik gekommen bin und sie hat mir
beim brief ging damals auch an sie
einfach gezeigt wie wichtig ist dass man
jeden brief wirklich individuell
persönlich wichtig nimmt und einfach
sieht welcher mensch dahinter steckt und
das ist so was was ich ja mitnehmen
werde auch wenn wir inhaltlich oder
vielleicht auch von der persönlichkeit
nicht immer auf einer linie liegen
werden ist das etwas was ich unglaublich
viel von ihr gelernt habe herzebrock
wäre es ihr politisches vorbild ich
würde gerne an dieser stelle einmal was
an merken wir ja darf weil ich es total
schön finde auch gerade zu hören dass
auch von frau die ein vorbild eine frau
in der politik ist und ich glaube das
ist etwas wo wir einfach auch gemeinsam
daran arbeiten müssen dass im parlament
insgesamt mehr frauen sitzen damit es
eben auch für mehr junge mädchen noch
weibliche vorbilder in der politik geben
kann damit wir irgendwann eine parität
erreichen können weil ich glaube dass ja
gerade sehr deutlich geworden ist die
vorbilder von frau und mir sind frauen
in der politik die eine starke rolle
gespielt haben uns unterstützt und
aufgefangen haben und ich glaube genau
dieses im parlament braucht es damit wir
sukzessive auch dahin kommen dass es
mehr weibliche repräsentation in der
politik gibt vielleicht dazu noch eine
sache zu den vorbildern der mir ja auch
imponiert hat unglaublich mit einem satz
den fand ich großartig war angela merkel
tatsächlich als bundeskanzlerin als die
bundeskanzlerin damals gesagt hat eines
ihrer schönsten momente oder sie hat
gesagt sie prägt es unglaublich dass
nach 16 jahren angela merkel jungen
fragen kann eigentlich auch ein mann
bundeskanzlerin werden und diesem satz
war nicht immer so großartig weil das
einfach auch zeigt das wie wichtig ist
es dass man frauen sieht in der politik
damit sich frauen auch oder mädchen das
vorstellen können sonst wird es sehr
lange dauern bis sich die nächste das
nächste mädchen noch die nächste frau
trauen wird zu sagen mein berufswunsch
ist bundeskanzlerin bundespräsident in
einer bundestags präsidentin oder unter
präsidentin daran müssen wir noch
arbeiten
börse wo ist denn angela merkel ihr
vorbild nach dem was wir jetzt ja so
gehört haben ich hätte jetzt als ich
gerade gerne auch vorweggenommen gesagt
dann für die jungen frauen kann ja
angela merkel dieses weibliche vorbild
sein die 16 jahre lang einen guten job
gemacht hat wirklich ja auch
international anerkannt ist und da als
erste deutsche kanzlerin eine sicherlich
eine vorreiterrolle eingenommen hat
übrigens nicht von der partei die von
quoten hatte aber das am rande ich finde
einfach die areale situation ist die wir
müssen unser wirtschaftssystem neu
erfinden damit wir eine klimafreundliche
der herr so was noch nie gekommen die
trotzdem wohlstand zu die frage war aber
die frage wer ist ihr posten im
wohlstand schafft und deswegen der
klassen l kommt drauf deswegen ist mein
vorbild heute ludwig erhard denn wie er
die marktwirtschaft neu erfunden hat als
soziale marktwirtschaft nach dem zweiten
weltkrieg müssen wir eben zu einer
klimafreundlichen marktwirtschaft kommen
und deswegen nehme ich ihn okay dann
hatte ich viel zu schnell unterbrochen
ok also ludwig erhard wer es eher
auf mich zu ändern und eine enorme
ich muss nicht sagen nun gestehen als
fdp ja sozusagen dass sich frau merkel
sehr schätze
persönlich und auch
fachlich sehr stark und ich bin mir ganz
sicher dass frau merkel in die
geschichte eingehen wird weil ich denke
kein anderer hat so gut hinbekommen wie
frau merkel einmal dass er zweiter ist
tatsächlich auch eine riesen vorbild für
mich persönlich weil er ja eigentlich
auch der grund ist warum ich bei der fdp
bin und das ist christian lender und
wenn er damals nicht gewesen wäre das
war 2016/17 meine ich eine veranstaltung
wo ich ihn kennenlernen durfte da war
ich noch nicht mitglied und habe mit ihm
geredet und er hat damals zu mir gesagt
schau her du bist das beste beispiel für
eine gelungene integration damals war es
ja mit der flüchtlingskrise diesem thema
und das war der punkt wo ich gesagt habe
okay ich trete die fdp ein und das ist
schon auch für mich ein riesen vorbild
oder er ist ein riesen vorbild für mich
persönlichen also wichtig höre ich bei
ihnen allen das ist halt eben konkrete
menschen gibt an dem sie sich
orientieren können weil bei ihnen ja
auch ganz wichtig vori jetzt zum schluss
haben wir noch drei minuten erst noch
mal für den schluss frau die was würden
sie sich wünschen wo sie sagen sie das
wäre dass das der wichtigste erst die
erste tat einer neuen regierung wenn es
eine ampelkoalition unter olaf scholz
gibt aber es hat olaf scholz glaube ich
selber ganz gut gesagt er hat ja
versprochen mit ihm wird es in zwölf
euro mindestlohn geben und das wird
vermutlich dann auch das erste sein was
wir anpacken werden und sie persönlich
müssen sich jetzt aber noch im büro und
wohnung und alles kümmern also sie haben
jetzt die nächsten wochen bis zum 26
oktober der bundestag sich zusammen dass
noch eine menge zu tun denn ja ich hab
jetzt tatsächlich
unterschlupf gefunden bei einer sehr
netten kollegen die jetzt uns ein raum
frei geräumt hat es ist tatsächlich sehr
viel im umbruch und es macht unglaublich
viel spaß ist es spannend aber ich
brenne war so nicht drauf und vermutlich
die anderen auch richtig loslegen zu
können endlich und alles das alles
organisatorische dann auch gemacht ist
ein fester was war für sie das
wichtigste erste was auf der agenda
stehen musste die erste tat einer
ampel-koalition wenn es sie denn geben
wird
ich glaube das was wir im wahlkampf auch
schon die ganze zeit gepredigt haben wir
brauchen jetzt ein starkes
klimaschutzgesetz ein sofortprogramm das
in den ersten 100 tagen große schritte
voran geht und ich bin mir aber ganz
sicher dass wir da auf gute lösungen
gemeinsam kommen und für mich persönlich
geht es darum die jugend zu vertreten
und für jugend teilhabe zu sorgen ok
herzustellen die sich ihre ersten tage
im bundestag jetzt vor sie waren jetzt
natürlich auch schon mal da müssen dann
von stuttgart immer pendeln sich um
ihren wahlkreis auch kümmern also was
was packen sie an als erstes
na gut ich hoffe immer noch dass
vielleicht doch noch die jamaika
koalition kommt und wir dann deutlich
mehr noch mitgestalten können und dann
denke ich sollten wir das thema
entbürokratisierung das beschleunigen
von planungsprozessen angehen als
allererstes weil wir brauchen ganz viele
windkraft kraftwerke wenn wir andere
kraftwerke abschalten wollen aber die
müssen gebaut werden genauso wie viele
andere dinge unsere wirtschaft muss am
laufen gehalten werden dafür brauchen
wir schnelle planungsprozesse wir
brauchen entbürokratisierung wir
brauchen eine entfesselung unserer
wirtschaft weil sonst wird das ganze
thema klimaschutz das thema
digitalisierung nicht zugucken sein okay
herr alan etwas was nehmen sie sich vor
jetzt die nächsten wochen wie sieht das
aus bis der bundestag konstituiert ist
ich glaube es mir zu tun ich denke dass
noch einiges zu tun und wir haben viel
zu tun und ich will jetzt nicht konkret
jetzt nur digitalisierung
bürokratieabbau klima ernennen sondern
tatsächlich in allen bereichen es gibt
viel zu tun und ich hoffe dass das jetzt
bald zu einer regierung konnte und dass
wir tatsächlich ein dorf arbeiten dürfen
natürlich das daraufhin sich schon so
ein
für mich persönlich ich habe nochmal im
büro nicht ich habe art übergangs büro
darf eine darf ein büro vor und
bundestagsabgeordneter nutzen aktuell
und ja das wird sich jetzt die nächsten
zwei wochen glaube ich ergeben dass wir
auch tatsächlich ort auch übergangs
büros oder und wie wäre es auch eine
idee dass sie sich als junge jetzt rede
ich mal von der ampelkoalition aber er
wirkt da vielleicht ja dann auch noch
damit dazu kommen dass sie sich als
jüngere abgeordnete mehr auch verbinden
das auf jeden fall also ich fand dass
ich finde das ganz ganz großartig vor
allen dingen weil es natürlich auch im
power und ist also pro fester und ich
habe mir grad auch darüber gesprochen
wie ein poren das ist wenn man sich
austauschen kann wie man wenn man
vorbilder hat aber wir werden trotz
aller inhaltlichen unterschiede werden
wir dieselben erfahrungen machen dass
wir auch mal an grenzen stoßen und da
mal einen austausch zu pflegen glaube
ich ist dann schon bereich hand für alle
ganz herzlichen dank ihnen für diesen
auftakt hier wir sind gespannt wir
werden sie natürlich weiter beobachten
bei völlig klar vielleicht einfach noch
mal zur erklärung wir haben hier immer
nur vier plätze und wir haben uns eben
für die für vertreter von den parteien
entschieden die dann ja wohl auch eine
regierung in irgendeiner form an einer
regierung beteiligt sein könnten
entweder jamaika oder ampel
vielen dank ihn hier allen und vielen
dank ihnen weil fürs zuschauen jetzt
fällen kommt für nix der tag